[Música]
nosotros continuamos Porque en lituania
se prepara para el inicio de la Cumbre
de los líderes de la otan este 11 y 12
de julio para el encuentro Los 16
aliados de la organización han enviado
alrededor de mil soldados para reforzar
la seguridad y otros están
proporcionando sistemas avanzados de
defensa aérea de los que carecen los
estados bálticos temas como la guerra en
Ucrania marcarán la agenda de este
evento para el análisis saludamos a
mikele testone y él es profesor de
relaciones internacionales y secretario
de la asociación de estudios
transatlánticos Bienvenido a France 24
hablemos primero de este vasto
dispositivo de seguridad de la Cumbre es
normal ante una reunión como esta o se
da más que todo por el contexto de la
guerra
muy buenos días y buenas tardes que
desde España y pues bastante las dos
cosas es normal que una cumbre de este
talante este protegida para un número
muy elevado de fuerza de seguridad y
además como usted acaba de decir las
circunstancias y la la el lugar donde
esta Cumbre tiene va a ocurrir necesita
un sistema de protección más numeroso y
sobre todo sobre todo más evidente que
es la diferencia estábamos mencionando
que uno de los temas que sin duda Va a
estar en el centro del debate pues es la
guerra en Ucrania el secretario general
de la otan ya entonces había dicho que
sus integrantes reafirmarán su apoyo
para que quien sea parte de la alianza
Pero esto cuando termine la guerra Hoy
está el temberg afirmó que van a
estudiar reducir de dos a un solo paso
el proceso de adhesión de Ucrania
Podemos esperar algo más que una simple
declaración
pues lo dudo lo dudo muy muy claramente
comparto al revés la declaración es del
presente norteamericano Joe biden que
Ucrania hasta que no termine la guerra
no va a entrar en la otan no hay no hay
Por qué Y por supuesto estamos todo lo
aliados dando nuestra ayuda económica
política y militar a Ucrania nuestra
simpatía pero
el ingreso un posible ingreso de Ucrania
en la otan podría ser muy
muy dañino para la otan misma y entonces
lo que se está hablando en esta semana
de intentar entablar un modelo israelí
el estilo no del de la alianza informal
entre Estados Unidos e Israel podría ser
una solución mejor para Ucrania todo lo
que estamos esperando la declaración
final como usted ha dicho que va a
producirse supuestamente el miércoles
Cuáles son la garantía de seguridad que
la otan va a proporcionar a Ucrania Pero
por supuesto en el futuro inmediato hay
mucho temas que
que no dan no que Ucrania no puede
entrar en la otan y la otan no quiere
que Ucrania entre en la alianza
justamente le pregunto con un eventual
fin de la guerra que le falta a Ucrania
qué requerimientos faltan para que pueda
hacer parte de la otan
pues le faltan muchas cosas porque
aunque no hay
un listado legal de medidas para el para
que cualquier estado europeos entre en
la otan
Ucrania tiene que trabajar primero en su
economía y una economía que va a ser
está destrozada por supuesto por la por
la guerra en su tiene que trabajar en su
criterios democráticos
constitucionales esto es un tema
supuestamente muy importante por la otan
Aunque la política podría decidir al
revés en las fuerzas armadas ucranianas
desde luego se están demostrando una una
interconexión y no entero
interoperabilidad muy fuerte con la otan
Pero primero hay que como el mismo
presente biden acaba de decir
primero hay que Establecer un alto el
fuego primero tiene que terminar la
guerra que Ucrania en su complejo entra
en la otan puede ser que se van a
producir dos ucranes como hubo dos
alemanias al final de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y una entre en la otan y la otra
entre en la zona de influencia rusa pues
esto no lo sabemos por supuesto el
ucraniano no quiere ni tampoco por
momento la sociedad occidental así que
tenemos mucho trabajo por delante y hay
muchas reformas económica militares
política y social que Ucrania tiene por
delante bueno algo que llama la atención
es el apoyo que Turquía que el
presidente revienta ahí Perdón le ha
dado a esta membresía de Ucrania
eventual membresía de Ucrania Cómo se
percibe este respaldo tensa de alguna
manera las relaciones entre ankara y
Moscú
bueno no yo diría que no todo el mundo
sabe que a pesar de que Turquía es un
miembro de la otan desde 1952
Turquía a Turquía sobre todo su presente
erdogan le gusta jugar de manera un poco
libre y Turquía
antes que china intentó y sigue
intentándose en un país negociador por
muchas razones sobre todo geográfica
económicas
Turquía el país que controlo los
estrechos Y entonces todo el tráfico
comercial desde el mar Negro al mar
Mediterráneo Turquía tiene interés que
la guerra se pare entonces Turquía
en su posición de diferente no con
respecto a la gran mayoría de los Aliado
otan sigue intentando este papel
negociador
No creo que la iniciativa turca tenga
mucho mucho éxito porque el mismo dijo a
celensky con una mano yo te voy a apoyar
para que tu país entre en la otan pero
el otro con la otra mano te voy a pedir
que de encontrar una paz justa y esto
podemos pensar en manera muy diferente
Pero me parece que todavía muy temprano
para hablar una paz justa bueno algo que
también
Ucrania bueno Ucrania obtuvo el respaldo
Turco pero el respaldo más bien retórico
que político algo que también llama la
atención justamente sobre el papel de
Turquía es lo que llaman brechas para
que Turquía de su vista Bueno a la
adhesión de Suecia de qué brechas
estamos hablando
Bueno hablamos de
una política tradicional consolidada
independientemente del gobierno de los
gobiernos que hay en estocolmo es decir
una política muy abierta de Suecia de
acogida de prófugopolíticos entre los
cuales lo kurdos y hemos visto en la
última semana o los últimos meses en el
pasado no quema del libro del Corán en
Suecia
Suecia siempre ha tenido esta como se
decía esta actitud de respaldo no de la
minorías en general de respeto a los
derechos humanos y entonces el tema de
cómo la por un lado Turquía y los turcos
Ven a La minoría curda y y lo que una
parte la parte más politizada más
Revolucionaria del movimiento de
independencia del kurdistán ha hecho
como acciones de guerrilla con acciones
de sabotear a todo lo que es Turco y de
otro lado la fuerza negocial ahora mismo
de erdogan después de su reelección no
en la
última elección es turca Así que
hablamos de entendimiento lo que
tú Suecia los turcos dicen tiene que
hacer es relajar
suavizar esta política de soporte de de
ayuda a La minoría kurdas lo que los
suecos piden a Turquía es de también
entender lo que son la necesidad de la
cultura política de Suecia y el hecho
que Suecia con su democracia consolidada
y con sus fuerzas armadas muy eficiente
puede proporcionar en términos positivos
a la defensa y a la de terrencia de toda
la alianza pues señor testimonio usted
muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24
Muchas gracias a vosotros y a ustedes
gracias por su sintonía nosotros hacemos
una breve pausa aquí en directo a
América ya regresamos